we have a train therefore she said I
didn't change I do not have to touch or
the power well this is a DC comic book
property part of the DC EU and it's the
story of Billy Batson he's a foster kid
who gets brought into this family
against the power of Shazam transer
shows all about his really excited when
I heard that they were making the Shazam
movie because I read the Geoff Johns
Shazam arc the new 52 one I thought it
was great I didn't really care about
Suzanne before that and I was like
that's actually a really compelling
character you kind of made Billy Batson
a bit of a dick bit of a problem child
there's no the arc is how you have this
power so maybe you can be better it
doesn't look like from the trailer at
least this movie's going that route it
looks like a pretty good kid I guess the
power issues am from the wizard Shazam
played by that Guardians actor that was
in that Guardians movie that one time
apparently guys come on it's Djimon
Hounsou what Blood Diamond counts for
nothing that's just weird I see that a
lot now whenever someone was in a Marvel
movie no matter what they've done before
that articles are always like Marvel
actor another conversation for another
time but point is he's now Shazam
Zachary Levi is perfect he has a comedic
youthful charm to him I don't know if
your suits padded maybe he just got
jacked up but personality-wise he's
still a kid in an adult's body I always
thought the rock would have been a good
Shazam but the rock was cast is Black
Adam who's not in this movie apparently
maybe they're saving that big Throwdown
for the sequel if this movie does well
and that's what they really play up they
play up the fun time of these kids like
I have superpowers now I'm a big adult
and I had never even thought of the
concept of all those superpowers do you
have like I don't know there's some
trial and error to find out what
superpowers he has this movie seems to
commit to the fund that this movie can
have which is funny that's one of the
complaints from one corner of one corner
of the Internet one of the things that
keep hearing in conversations and I'm
guilty of it too I've said this is I
wish the DC movies were more fun they
don't have to necessarily lend
themselves to that apparently they
listen to it it looks like this movies a
fun movie
walked away from this trailer with a
smile on my face because that's the
time-honoured all unifying fantasy of
every kid every youth I want to have
superpowers what superpowers would I
have what would I do if I had on my
friend and I used to imagine we had
superpowers you know when we were
younger my younger I mean yesterday my
favorite shot is just simply this one
that's legit I'm not gonna lie if I saw
this kid walking with this costume dude
I think it was a little strange
especially when he's zapping phones no
one's like do you have lightning powers
dude but it doesn't matter he doesn't
need a mask no one knows his identity
he's like hey I look like this don't
worry when I say Shazam I'm gonna turn
into a kid again and you're definitely
not gonna Who I am not gonna pose not
gonna posture don't know who this guy is
well the character not the actor I know
the actors mark Strong you still know
who the character is maybe it's Sinestro
it's not I know my comment section right
now is blowing up like the trailer does
such a good job at bringing me into the
concept of this kid who gets superpowers
so he and his friends are just kind of
figuring it out maybe having a bit of
fun that's interesting enough that
sounds like big like big if it were a
superhero movie now I'm waiting for
Shazam and Lex Luthor to be on one of
those big floor keyboard things if
there's not a big reference in this
movie somewhere I'd be baffled doesn't
it has to be I'm just saying the
opportunity lends itself maybe it's just
too easy to take so they won't they're
so interested in that element of it I
don't even care who the villain is you
can keep the villain small you have a
good introduction to the hero looks like
there might from a trailer from a couple
minutes I've seen which really could be
edited any which way to show me that
we're looking forward to this it still
got to talk about the Aquaman trailer I
don't even seen it I just wanted to keep
my eye on Shazam right now but first Sam
I'm really impressed I think it's a
movie that the DC EU really needs right
now so bring it on
and just to break tracks and now we're
gonna go over here because there's no
way to transition this but I saw a
couple people in my last video wondering
like well why didn't you say anything
about Jon Schnepp Jon Schnepp who passed
away he passed away yesterday which is
why I didn't get my glass video up
yesterday the reason I haven't talked
about it aside from my Instagram post
that I made about it is I just don't
want to talk about it because it wasn't
an industry person to me he was a dude I
actually I knew and I talked to and I
enjoyed spending time with him so as I'm
just I'm processing the fact that this
person whose company I really enjoyed is
no longer with us I I just don't want to
talk about it right now because in
moments of grief I don't look I don't
want to just throw things out there and
talk I want to get my own head and cry
but I will greatly
[ __ ] miss him I did an Instagram post
please take that as those are my
thoughts she never would know who that
villain was he can correct me right now
he'd love these trailers that are coming
out [ __ ] but appreciate your
understanding and all that so the Shazam
trailer have you seen that what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more and stay sweating
[Music]